dear diary is sort of a funny story a
few months ago I met Jack so it love
took six hours what I lasted six hours a
puppet show that auntie bridge went to
fill not I don't know about it and how
much you need to make he has a pretty
nice sized puppet and then the next week
you were a little kiss you know on the
forehead there uh what's talking about
the baby mark my ex and I had similar
relations booster Daffy I can't go back
and keep making same mistakes I'm
pregnant when I can make new ones so you
have no idea which of us is the father
surely one of those days more likely
they're basically likely so do bring
along the father if you can work out
which one he is for better or worse fate
has brought us together both of you stop
it
where you're nice tea thank you I
brought you a super juice oh let me
carry that for you too can I carry your
phone Bridget who do you want to be the
father I don't know it's like the final
of the X Factor da 0 1 if you wanted to
be mark at 02 if you wanted to be in my
mind around a copy I have been in the
past and me I could be okay how do you
orchestrate such cliffhangers in your
life this is not how i thought this be
but however we choose to do this the
most important thing is the baby
good god Bridget Gary mint 642 men huh
Oh which of you is the father all right
right and who do we have here I'm
Brigitte and this is Jack and this is
Mark lovely you're our second same-sex
couple today the reality was much more
single
screw off